hello I'm Nick Larkin Doha the top
stories here on Al Jazeera and
Australia's most decorated living
Soldier Ben Robert Smith has lost a
landmark defamation case against
newspapers which accused him of war
crimes in Afghanistan the judge says the
papers proved truth in some of the most
serious allegations Sarah Clarke has
more from outside the courtroom in
Sydney
this was Ben Robert Smith he was taking
these three newspapers took the federal
court accusing them of defamation
portraying him falsely portraying him as
a war criminal now that case was
dismissed by the Justice head or the
judge here today by the city court so
the media here those reporters in
particular Nick McKenzie and Chris
Masters who wrote those articles they
have tweeted noted this is Justice for
press Freedom it's also Justice for the
media's job to undertake these public
investigations into matters of public
interest so it's a loss a massive loss
for Ben Robert Smith in that particular
case he has been found to be involved in
some of those unlawful killings and that
was during his deployment in the SAS
regiment in Afghanistan between 2009 and
2012.